Hello everyone, this is Frankie Freitas, and welcome to another week of HoloTalk for the week of December 13th, 1998.
I was going to actually take a holiday, but because of all the happenings with the new laser pointer discoveries, I decided to hang in there for another week to bring another report to you.
I've been in the lab for a while, so I have some information on laser pointer holography for you.
As you may remember, a few weeks ago, Steve Michael came on the show and told us that he had created a 4x5-inch reflection and laser transmission hologram using a laser pointer.
And this created quite a stir.
And I went out and got a laser pointer on my own.
Now he got one from the Edmund Scientific Catalog, I believe he paid $49 for it.
I found one at a drugstore called Eckerd Drugs, which is a subsidiary of JCPenney, so I imagine it's a national drugstore chain.
And I got mine for $7.99, $650 nanometers, 5 milliwatts.
So I bought one, brought it home, got things set up, did a hologram, and I was absolutely surprised when I uh saw the results from this $799 laser pointer.
So I went out and I bought a bunch of other ones.
Since that time, I have a number of different things to uh update you on to possibly get you started as well with laser pointer holography.
Uh you know, it's really funny.
I was going over one of the old catalogs from 1991 because I I keep everything.
The lowest price laser pointer in this 1991 catalog was $140.
It was a three milliwatt operating at 670 nanometers.
That was their lowest price, and they had that exclamation points uh next to that.
Like, like you know, wow, grab this now.
Uh, they were still selling the small handheld helium neon tubes.
These are small helium neon battery operated lasers that you could hold in the palm of your hand, and uh they actually put out one milliwatt, and their price was 279.
There were a few other pointers on the page as well.
None of them were very uh powerful.
I don't believe any of them went over one milliwatt, to tell you the truth, except for that uh that lowest price one, which was around three.
Uh a point nine milliwatt was selling, this is a pointer, at two hundred and fifty-nine dollars.
And there was another one on the page that said solid state laser pointer, which to me a diode would be solid state laser, so I'm not quite sure what that was referring to, but in any case, that was a half a milliwatt to one milliwatt output at six hundred and seventy seventy nanometers at three hundred and sixty-nine dollars for a half milliwatt to one milliwatt laser pointer back in 1991.
$369.
And once again, uh the hologram that I created was using a five milliwatt 650 nanometer laser pointer for seven dollars and ninety-nine cents.
Now, why is this such a big deal?
Uh obviously, you're coming on the show and you're listening to me talk about this, and you know I'm very excited about it.
I am, I'm just beside myself.
I mean, what a wonderful time of the year to have a discovery like this.
It's it's almost magical to me.
I feel young and like a kid again.
I'm back in the lab working with things uh and discussing things all over again.
And you know, holography is very magical.
Uh you you really get bit with the holography bug when you get started with holography.
And that's probably one of the big things with this is the fact that we really do need to bring more people into holography, but it's so restrictive.
Basically, it boils down to money.
That's what it everything always always boils down to.
And there are places that sell surplus and manufacturers overruns lasers, and they're very good lasers.
I have one myself, which I use in my lab all the time too.
But you're still looking at an outlay, an initial outlay of maybe a 150 to 200 dollars to get into the five milliwatt range or so.
Even if it were only a hundred dollar output of money, uh you still can't compare that to eight bucks.
And that's what's really exciting about this because that is the biggest outlay that you uh make when you're beginning holography.
And you can't go any further in holography until you take that first step and begin it.
You have to start.
And once you do start, there is no feeling on the face of this earth, well, maybe a couple, but no feeling on the face of this earth that compares to seeing that first hologram that you've made.
Once that's in your system, it's in your system.
And I've been making holograms for years and years and years, and I still go down into the lab occasionally, someone wants to have a hologram made, or I have workshops or things like that.
But it's basically the same thing for me all the time.
It's been that way for years.
But this is something brand new.
And I'd also like to announce, which I don't think I have in my notes here, and I don't know how I miss that.
I'm also running this uh laser pointer off of a power supply that you can pick up at just about any radio shack or Best Buy or any place that you see that sells the AC to DC converters for uh walkmans, cassette players, uh C players and things of that nature that usually run off of batteries, but you can also run them off the house current.
This laser takes four point five volts.
Now it's Thursday night.
I'm doing the show a little bit early and I started this laser on the power supply Sunday night and it's still going.
It's still going, so no cost of batteries or anything anymore.
And it's very inexpensive, you know.
Um and it's portable.
It's small in size, it's because it is battery powered, if you don't want to run it off of a power supply, uh you can go and make holograms when no powers available.
I got an email from someone and I won't say their name because I'd I'd like to get them on the show and they're thinking about it, so I'll I don't want to scare them away before I can even get them on the show.
But it's a husband and wife team and they go into caves and do holography.
Uh the the formations that are in some of the caves.
They take in their plates, they take in a helium neon laser, and they lug a large battery power supply, which they put into a backpack and tie with the rope to their feet so that as they crawl through the tight spaces of the cave, they have to pull this battery pack along with them that runs the helium neon laser power to the head.
And this was the greatest thing that came down the pike for them.
This guy now has something that may weigh two ounces that he can put in his pocket and take it in with him and uh him and his wife can do holograms inside the cave without worrying about the helium neon laser and the power supply that has to go with it.
Because I imagine that battery pack must have some weight to it to drag that thing through a cave.
Not that you get me in a cave to begin with anyway.
And this opens holography to many new people, which is what we need.
We need more people doing holograms.
And finally, finally, we have something that will allow people to do that.
It need holography needs a good shot in the arm with new young, talented practitioners.
We need some youth and new ideas.
I think this is one of the ways that we can at least, at least have them take that first initial step where it's not going to break the bank, and if they don't like it, they haven't put out a large amount of money and lost it.
Who cares?
Who cares if you spent eight bucks and you get some chemistry or borrow some chemistry from a photography friend and set something up and start to shoot a couple holograms to see if you like it?
You can always move on.
Go out and get that 30 milliwatt heaney or that twenty-watt argon.
But you have to start somewhere, and this is the perfect place to start.
Not to mention schools on real tight budgets.
Teachers, they don't always have money.
You know, schools they don't have any money.
Especially for sciences.
Now I don't want to get on that kick.
But sciences and things, you know, there's no money for that.
No money for that.
I won't say where the money goes.
Now what can we do with these laser pointers?
Well, there's different types of holograms that can be made.
So far, we've got single beam laser transmission and reflection holograms.
And I know I remember reading quite a few articles about a technique to do single beam white light transmission holograms.
Along with white light transmission holograms that you do not have to do a slip master first.
So I will continue to look into that.
I have not had the time to go through the back issues.
I believe it may have been in either Laser News or Holosphere or one of those publications that goes back probably to the uh late 80s or so, I believe.
I'll find it, but I haven't I haven't had the time to look.
And it's possible to do a split beam.
Let me tell you something.
I burnt one of these diodes out.
I wanted to see, it's you know, eight bucks.
I figured let's let's see what this baby can take.
So I got the power supply, and I've got different settings on there, you know, 3 volts, 4.5, 6 volts, uh, 7 something, 8, 10, 12.
I think I got up to around 10 or 12 before I saw that that white uh puff of smoke come out and the thing blank out on me.
Uh so what I did is I figured, well, this baby shot.
So I got the second one that I bought and opened that up and hooked it up to the power supply and made sure I kept the power at 4.5 volts this time.
And I'll tell you something, this second one's a lot brighter than the other one was.
So there must be some sort of a variation in the actual power output sometimes of these diodes.
But I'll tell you something.
I've worked I began holography with a 5 milliwatt back in when I started this studio in 1983 from uh AeroTech, which was out.
Let me see how well my memory serves me.
Zeta VETA Zeta Drive, Pittsburgh, Pennsylvania.
I think I paid $680 for a 5 milliatt that was a self-contained tube and power supply in a cylindrical housing.
I believe that was what it was.
And if memory serves me right, I'm looking over at the table right now.
I think this is just as bright as that 5 milliwatt Heaney.
This little laser diode that I have on here right now is screaming.
It's really screaming.
So I'm I'm going to try and do a split beam hologram using this laser.
And that of course will open things up to other things as well.
This is what's so exciting about it.
This is what's so exciting is because all the adventure's still there.
I mean, it's a it's a whole new road that hasn't yet been traveled.
You know?
I don't need a 20 watt argon to make me happy.
This stuff is what's hot right now.
This is exciting.
And of course, some advanced techniques.
Now remember, you can do multiple color holography using a single wavelength.
It's done way back in the early uh 80s or mid eighties.
Um probably one of the first names that comes to mind doing that work is John Kaufman.
And uh multicolor using triethanolamine.
And all of these techniques can be found in just about any holography book.
So you've got your five milliwatt laser diode, uh, you're ready to do your hologram.
And if you want to start experimenting with a number of different things that could be considered a little bit more advanced work, you can get into the triethanolamine technique and start doing some multiple color single beam holograms if if it turns out that uh split beams just a little bit too much for these diodes right now.
And who knows what's coming down the pike.
Who knows?
How long is it going to be before we have a 25 milliwatt uh 650, 640, 635 nanometer diode that's a hundred bucks.
That's something.
Of course, eight by tens is a question.
And just like I had mentioned that I think this laser's uh a little bit more powerful than the first one I had in there.
Judging from my eyes and what I see as far as a spread over a four by five area that I have set up right now, I think it may be possible to do a single beam eight by ten.
If it's a good system, good table, good solid table that's not going to bend and twist and not getting a lot of vibration.
I think it may be possible to do it.
And all of these things are coming up.
Boy.
Wow.
What are the drawbacks?
Well, I guess you know that ag the materials are hard to find.
We are working with some materials that are less sensitive than what the ag for was, and what this works out to be is actually longer exposure times, longer exposure times.
And you can get around that.
Four by five holograms are no problem with this laser diode.
Uh, this is I'm reading from notes that are actually a little bit further down on the page, but my exposure time for this four by five plate was four seconds.
And I was going by I used the science and mechanics meter and the holography handbook, basically the chart that's in there for single beams when I do them.
And I was getting a 10 reading on a two scale.
Which worked out to, I believe it may have been two seconds.
And of course, I always double that for reflection holograms.
So if you have some materials that you have to buy that are less sensitive than the AgFa 8075 HD, make smaller holograms.
You know?
Go smaller.
Can still make them.
Get started.
The hologram I made, and anyway, it makes no holog without jumping ahead.
What's the difference?
If you've got a five milliwatt Heaney, or you've got a five milliwatt diode, you're still working with five milliwatts, so you're still going to have the same problem with each one.
So you either have a problem with something you paid $200 for, or you're going to have a problem with something that you paid $799 for.
Your choice.
It was 4x5 on an Agpha 8075 HD glass plate, was Frosty the Snowman, and that's another funny thing that you see on test holograms.
Uh holographers must just run around the house or run around the studio and just pick up anything that they see to put in the because a lot of the test holograms that I've seen was like, you know, there were absolutely no thought going into anything.
Including this one.
I mean, Frosty the Snowman.
What does that say?
Nothing.
But you grab whatever you can grab because I think a lot of times you're just in a hurry and excited to get a a shot off.
The exposure time was four seconds, and that's using the chart in the holography handbook.
It was a ten reading on a two scale.
It was spatial filter.
I sent the light through a spatial filter.
Now Steve Michael said he was having problems with his laser sending it through a spatial filter because of the elliptical uh beam profile that came out of the diode.
I believe the laser that I have has colonnading optics in there because I get a beautiful dot on the wall.
I it goes through the spatial filter with absolutely no problem at all, and it's a beautiful spread of a wavefront of light coming out of that spatial filter.
And what I'm gonna have to do is I'm gonna have to get some photographs taken um with the digital camera or whatever, just to show you the quality of what's happening with this with these layered laser diodes because you know, seeing is believing.
Uh development was uh D nineteen uh developer and the bleach was the uh standard uh anything goes potassium bromide, potassium ferrocyanide bleach, uh that I just happened to have mixed that was old.
It was really old.
I think it may have been left over from uh summertime or something like that, but I didn't want to mix anything new up.
I'm going to get back in the lab and uh start with some pyro uh the pyrochrome process and uh which I'm a little bit more familiar working with with uh reflection holograms.
But in any case, there you have it folks.
Uh what we have on tap for you this week.
I called L Michael Roberts, who is uh the uh webmaster at uh Laser FX, and he deals a lot with uh laser legislation and he's a contact person for the laser industry in the press, and he was nice enough to come on the show and give some comments on the legislation and law behind laser diodes and just as a coincidence I'm driving home tonight and it says that Nair Rendell is signing a bill into law in Philadelphia that you have to be 18 years old to purchase a laser pointer in Philadelphia and they also are going to there's a bill that's been introduced to legislate its use and that's all I could get out of it so if I can get some more information as far as what they mean by that legislating its use if all of a sudden the only thing that these stupid laser pointers were used for was to go to concerts and try and hit the singer in the eye or whatever everybody's doing with these things out there and all of a sudden it comes along that for a very reasonable amount of money actually almost a fantasy amount of money some people still don't believe it yet that you can create three dimensional laser holograms and these things can actually turn people on to a field that they may pursue later on in college physics optics and all of a sudden they're gone.
You can't even get them anymore.
I don't think that's going to happen.
Buy a bunch of them folks I think they have a life of like a hundred thousand hours so get them now.
Stock up and also this week we'll be playing the Steve Michael interview the original interview and just to show how fast the world is moving.
It's old news already.
But there's so many requests to hear it that I'm putting it up again and uh I hope you enjoy it.
It was certainly a pleasure doing it.
I've been in contact a few times since with Steve Michael, uh, both by email and on the phone.
And uh we're going to continue with this.
We're going to continue pushing it because it's just an absolutely incredible thing.
I'm just so excited about it.
So thank you for tuning in this week.
I'm taking some time off.
The next show will be January 10th.
I'm going to be replaying.
I had a couple requests for some shows like the holographic heart.
Uh, that's going to go up, I believe, in a week.
Uh so I've had some requests to do a few repeats.
So I'll put those on uh while I'm on holiday.
And I want to thank everyone for tuning in.
And I hope you're as excited about this as I am.
Even if you're working in a lab with a 20 watt argon, come on.
Be excited.
This is really exciting stuff.
It really is.
Where's the little kid in you?
Especially this time of year.
It's so magical, you know, to be down here working with this again, and it's so much discovery involved.
And then I go upstairs and it's all Christmas lights and Christmas trees and all the sparkle and all this other kind of stuff.
What a perfect time of the year for this to happen.
It's really nice.
So thank you for tuning in.
This is Frank Defrates.
Have a great holiday season.
Have a great new year, 1999, last year of this century.
Wow.
It's also a great time of the century for this to happen, too, boy.
This is holography 21st century.
So uh take care.
And I'll see you next year, God willing.
It's been an honor being your host on this show for a season and a half, and I look forward to continue doing this and continuing to allow it to grow and evolve into whatever it is that it grows and evolves into.
Take care.
This is Frank Defratis for HoloTalk.